welcome to this video this is me being
black here was top y'all off okay let's
see what i can let me play something
else a talk on red chili yep ok so the
kuro not a very frequent opponent of
them frequent opening that I employ but
it's interesting to switch gears once in
a while so why not the carol yeah Knight
f6 is a somewhat rare reply to white
line you but it's something that I have
from studied some time ago when I
compile the repertoire for black for the
ICC on the calc on um what is this 22
hmm there's something wrong with
developing here I don't think so 22 is
kind of clawing up his development so
I'm not quite sure if this is a great
idea let's see if I take on f3 now I
basically have gained a tempo yeah let's
do that I mean gee takes looks really
wrong so Queen takes and now I've gained
a temple over conventional lines where
black plays Bishop g4 and then captures
so I'm a tempo up on something that is
considered to be okay anyway cannot be
that bad so I wait I don't need to take
I can also play Queen to be six I think
this is sometimes an idea looking at the
beetle porn yes this gives me maybe
something more to work with later I was
something that I can attack I wonder if
I castle now let's castle first I was
thinking night BTW 7 but maybe I even
want a knight on c6 hmm is if either
move
I mean if either probably have to play
anyway so let's go in five if he cancels
now I probably want to take yep to make
sure that this Bishop is not escaping
and now let's go see five min 96 I
really want the knight on c6 there's no
particular reason to put it on to put it
on d 7 so he wants to go with a form
that's understandable and I really only
like to take this if possible Quincy 7f
40 eggs rook takes knight c6 mmmm that
cannot be bad really so let's do that
the queen is somewhat under fire anyway
with the possible nights you for coming
ok so he starts with 94 let's go or 96
as planned ok no I didn't I didn't
expect that hmm this allows me to play
with maybe ninety eight or nine to d6
let's do that not sure now if he wants
to play a for he wants to play a form
hmm interesting
yeah do I go f6 or not I can also just
take T group chicks I'm not sure about
96 the South pin looks a bit tricky
right as it is tricky and best best
avoided oh he if he lost the Queen trade
uh-huh I thought I didn't really had on
my radio at all as this now looks quite
nice long term with the the bishop only
true not being the best piece it is
looking at it better now but he still
keeps all his pawns on light squares and
potentially my night is much stronger
than his bishop the position is still
fairly closed hmm an interesting
question is if i should play 95 soon
what if i should avoid that not clear if
he goes Bishop d7 i have this choice of
playing 95 or night before night before
it's also really interesting trying to
try to make sure that he's sort of bound
to or tied to the sea to porn so let's
do this now I want to get rid of that
night on c4 and if you just trades
everything my position is strategically
very nice so that won't happen I guess
maybe he will play 95 but yeah but not
not just trade everything okay um I
think just ruki 8 looks no I can also
take of course but whether this is not
bad I mean every trade here that leaves
night and bishop on the board will get
me closer to a better endgame main ideas
now to just take on c4 and play rupee
five
yep that I overlooked not good not good
hmm okay not ideal but Flynn then just
go back why not nothing bad happen to
you ready okay what about this I can go
rook e8 just the other one yeah one
minute 17 this is kind of tricky can pre
move that but I don't really expect him
to take no that's a good more bit more
interesting okay now is going back hmm
this is a good night Knight to f5 as
possible but not really doing that much
so let's go over to before
time morning I just prevent you five for
the moment okay is it is it dangerous or
anything I mean I can take twice let's
go back here and see if I can get up get
rid of the night just easier to play if
the night is going even though I'm not
sure that it helps me objectively but
40-something seconds is kind of tricky
check yeah that's a nice position not
sure why they where this is headed
I can just check the rook how is he
covering it oh ok this is all so simple
look over to f6
I have to speed up vintage rusty after
being away a couple of days not playing
a single game yeah been to Berlin
watching rod rapid and blitz but
watching it doesn't mean you're
practicing check check
yep position is very nice I know that
that helps a lot in terms of the time
can play much quicker now and plenty of
pre moves possible check oops check
check just no stalemate please check
check check mate yeah I'm glad to get
that winning let's have a look there
yeah this line is a somewhat rare one
but it's not so bad however Queenie to
is a very uncommon reply I guess
normally white go see five and then
after 94 he has a choice of what to play
maybe 92 as a possibility recently that
was played against me in a game and then
Queen B 6 is played d for andy sixx kind
of like a french but this is a night
only for that add some some additional
gaffe flavor to the position um yeah he
went here after which I can certainly
take that's that's probably going to be
fine with the normal CARICOM type of
position but here this is interesting
I'm not quite sure if white really has a
much better move now than h3 maybe you
can go t for something I don't know
taking is interesting maybe like this
and create five this is an interesting
idea maybe man that's not so easy
because I don't want to do this this is
this is looking
good so hmm ok maybe maybe I have to
take here and this kind of position
that's probably equal ish White has two
bishops but his knight on c3 is really
misplaced and he has lost some time at
the Queen okay well this and now I have
the main line with extra tempo usually
white eggs on a three in one go III we
should be for that oh this is played no
Queen B Thicke's b6 i think is useful
just to annoy right a little bit of
threatening to take here and take one be
too so b3 is kind of logical castles it
should be 25 i am the computer points
out this as a possible improvement yeah
I have to agree this is very awkward
white cannot castle because of the pin
the computer wants to go Bishop f1 now
and then Queen d1 very long long and
kind of elaborate plan but how do you
untangle em that's better the KE 5
wasn't good so I mean I'm strategically
in good shape here but it's nothing
special 94 96 a for i was i was thinkin
f1 okay this takes and yeah this was
surprising to me I was thinking that
Rukia force kind of yeah the only move
in a way because you want to keep Queens
on in this kind of situation when you
have the bad bishop so strategically you
rather don't want to trade so I was a
bit surprised that she allowed that I
have six to make sure that I control me
five should you fry up here cover e6
okay fades 95 or normal this smooth or
looks very normal I think I mean I like
my position but probably it's nothing
nothing super great Luke back here 94 I
wanted to try to win of course rook e8
yeah where is it getting getting tricky
I wasn't really sold on the idea to take
yeah I don't think that this is so great
I mean it looks like weakness but my
night I mean if I could get in like h6
and night over 35 that would be nice but
he always has night f5 and it's rather
actor and so I regrouped to be form yeah
I wanted to stop gphi for the moment
maybe night f7 is an idea yeah that's
actually an interesting move try to
block both ok but I think this is kind
of normal when ok 25 try to be actors I
went here oh I a drug fjf 50 that means
g6 is a is a mistake definitely rookie
7i have to play or root is six something
like that that makes the whole procedure
actually a questionable of taking check
yeah rook ever fight is very very bad
now I have no move the check and here
I'm just lost well so Joe that probably
means that it was really a lot better to
play night f7 to just completely I'm
lucky I am to make sure that this is not
happening and I'm still have that hope
that long term that Bishop proves to be
a problem yeah there is much much better
so we had a huge opportunity there to
strike with root
five again Luke ffr he has saw it and I
saw that this is kind of okay but now
the tables are starting to turn as the
end game really is better for me oh i
blundered c5 he didn't take it you could
take care I didn't see that so shaky
game ready yeah I know I think this is
probably leading to problems yeah it's
not able to to keep that pawn there is
any chat not that rook yeah look
somewhat error ridden game but well
mistake reading game a bit as I said
with rusty after not playing for almost
one and a half weeks so I hope you
enjoyed the game thanks for watching